let's talk for a minute about pension
nobody's ever dared to make one of his
novels into a movie
what's it hard did you have to get his
permission was how did that come about
we contacted his represent yes you'd
heard that he was possibly open to an
adaptation of inherent vice and so I
contacted his agent and they said yes
that he was and I said that Paul was
interested and we found out that he was
also an admirer of Paul's work so there
was that and he said they sent over like
galley copies for Paul myself to read
and after that basically I just went
ahead and made the deal over a few years
took I think these were gallery covers
so you saw it before was published yes
uh-huh just about a month or so yeah it
wasn't very long Yeah right and then how
does a folder master yeah yeah and then
how did you how did you start how did
you get you've never really done a true
adaptation before I mean there will be
blood you took just the beginning of the
Upton Sinclair novel and then went off
in your own direction this one is very
faithful to the book mm-hmm and yeah I
did I did it the old-fashioned way where
I just got a cook book holder and I laid
out the book and I brought all those
typing skills that my mom paid for back
when I was a kid and I just typed out
the dialogue so that I could see it as a
script and as I was going you know
things were presenting themselves kind
of obviously as things it could be cut
or I thought some things were less
obvious and it was really just about
getting it out of being a book and into
the form of a script so I could look at
it in in in a format that I understood
more than anything just to see what I
suppose there could have been an easier
way she would call the publisher and
gotten a PDF paste but but the hard way
seemed good to just not keep keep
working with the material to get to know
it it came along at the right time for
me I mean I was sort of sick of the
sound of my own voice and I'd always
loved the pinch on when I thought about
trying other books that he'd written and
so to have this opportunity and to work
with this
Tyrael was kind of like you know having
a having a great having working with a
collaborator where normally had worked
alone and in my room and you just sort
of struggle through so I hate the word
masterclass but it feels like it fits
that I could to sit with his words and
look at how he turned words around and
put things together was like it was like
a shot in the arm for me you know to
just to be excited about writing again
be excited about this great job that I'm
able to do and I have and somehow I was
just not that high on it but by the end
of doing this I just I feel like I
learned a lot doing this so I was never
closed to it but I would I just I loved
writing and I loved and I had ideas
coming out of me that I could get down
but this one just came along at the
right time um it made me excited made me
feel lucky to be a writer I'm certainly
lucky to work with this book you know or
his words and at what point did did you
conceive of the idea of making sort of
ledge the narrator because she isn't the
narrator in the novel right she's a
supporting character in the book who
lives down at the beach and is really
into astrology and seems to say things
say beautiful things the the doc little
pieces of advice here and there and
somewhere after messing with it for
about a year it seemed that the the
story needed something else that needed
a way to bring some of the things that
pinch ons pyncheons verse into the
script as and also just as a helper to
an to the audience they might have
helped guide us through this kind of
elaborate crazy maze yeah um and add the
other things I think hand-in-hand was
that with the idea of having joanna
newsom who's a terrific singer and
harpist play the part so that kind of
made it fuller mm-hmm you kind of wrote
it for her voice uh started out being
nothing and then halfway through I
started to think boy there's only one
person that could play this kind of
Jiminy Cricket surfer girl character and
it was
huh and when you were reading the book
and thinking about the movie I mean with
E with the images in your mind at all
the images that we now see up on screen
well no they never are
there never there's just a vast distance
between the things you usually see in
your head and how they turn out there
were obviously photographs in the period
and and and yeah there were other films
and stuff but the fabulous furry freak
brothers was a great comic book it's
referenced in the book that was a kind
of a great thing because essentially
that's just like small little panel
square panels and these just dirty
filthy hippies just trying to score dope
you know and and and the stuff is so
funny and there's and the LAPD is jen is
almost LAPD it's just the cops the fuzz
is usually involved in there so
everything's kind of like that but
somewhere you know that's one thing but
the distance between those ideas and
really getting there and doing it is
usually kind of large so it seems hard
to remember even some of the original
ideas I might have had in my head by now
yeah and did things this is sort of for
you and then for Leslie did things
change much in the in the editing room
were there significant significant
temporal shifts or I wouldn't say
significant yeah but I would say that we
were editing and rewriting a lot as we
were going along so the way over yeah so
that by the time we act so much more
than we normally do Leslie was actually
on set a lot particularly in the last
two weeks when it was clear we were
going to finish shooting and we were
trying to get all the pieces of the
puzzle that we might need so that by the
time we got there to the editing room we
were working with what we knew we had
really yeah yeah I was the voice-over
just provided so much flexibility mmm
and you could go tone you could rewrite
that at any point it when you as an even
more expository it could be more lyrical
and mmm choose which direction we went
with the voice-over so that that really
I think we're always scared about too
much voiceover it was just
like when's too much you know so long
discussions about what's what's what's
the right amount yeah mark when you
approach this I mean one of the things
that I that I love about the movie is
that it doesn't really visually indulge
in in the usual sixties seventies
stereotypes
there's no psychedelic sequences it's no
you know nobody's with tambourines and
bell-bottoms and you know you managed to
I mean the costumes are very distinctive
dr. blatnoyd velvet suit stand up how
did you were you very conscious of
trying to avoid a certain cliches of the
of the period movies yeah um I've read
the book and took what I could from
pyncheons descriptions and then some of
the Marne it described and we decided
what piece would fit in the puzzle with
them and I think I've made a couple of
different colored suits for blatnoyd
pinch on describes it as ultraviolet you
know and then we did the more livable
plum and you know Paul's really
conscious of not overdoing it and far
and that's in turn makes me sort of pull
back and you know we don't want to
distract from a scene with a costume you
know and so I'm very happy with sort of
the laid-back way that it comes out
because you get it but it's not knocking
you over the head and it feels period
but it's also interesting to look at and
it's storytelling and character you can
do something that's entirely accurate to
the period I mean just ripped straight
from a photograph that you've seen
somebody wearing and and then you're
standing on set thing this is absolutely
preposterous you can't do this because
right you know it gets in the way of the
thing that you should be looking at
which is the actors of the story it just
becomes a costume performance right like
that is keeping an eye on that so over
the years of working together I know the
drill
like that we we want it to be there but
we don't want it to take over in any way
sling three four
five layers down was that all-american
family that actually brings the tope is
that in pinch honor absolutely wait he
describes it he describes the
all-american found in the one
description that I remember best is of
the daughter who has a future in drug
abuse
great yeah